alex kevin congratulations you guys are
in the third and final round of this
competition which means that you're both
one step closer to the title of fortune
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars
all you need to do now is go home and
recreate this
iconic weapon from history
the spa the good luck bladesmiths we'll
see you in four days
good luck kevin
so it's day one in belleville west
virginia i got a spot
to go make let's get crack-a-lackin
i'm gonna be using 5160 it's a forgiving
medium
it'll bring some strength to whatever
they're gonna smash cut break
kill so i'm gonna try big sexy first to
bash down the width of that material to
about two and a half
two and a quarter inches wide
come on dang it work
four days is it enough time to make a
spava
you don't know what the complication is
gonna be
oh she's getting there though i slowly
started drawing it out i'm about 35
inches long
you know it's just patience getting the
equipment to work right
tomorrow pressure will be on because i
got to get this thing quenched
if i don't i'm behind the ball whoa
definitely excited to be back home back
in my shop where i'm nice and
comfortable
i'm gonna do a uh full damascus blade
with a little bit of a
ladder pattern in it i'm really looking
forward to
going all out and making something
really cool to impress the judges
first press was just nice and quick and
light just to push everything together
this next press be a little more
aggressive probably the most important
part of this entire build
my welds seem to have sucked pretty well
i'm gonna start drawing this thing out
i've got one seam that came apart i
think if i just flex it
get it hot and press it again should be
okay let's hope
this might be a make or break moment
right here
i really hope that's the only one but
deep down i'm
petrified that there's going to be more
of these seams opening up throughout
this billet
as i go start drawing this billet out a
big seam just opens up
right in the center of my billet so i
think my best bet
is going to be to break the spill in
half salvage as much welded steel as i
possibly can
and i'll just do a generic random
pattern damascus
but it'll still be a damascus sword
[Music]
well the good news is both of those seem
really solid so
at least got something out of there
today i need to get the blade done and
quenched
so i got the shoulders put in i have the
medial ridge where you can distinctly
see
where it's starting to come together
it's time for the quench
oh
yeah look at that
we're quenching again because i don't
have time to eff around with the
normalization
because i went all the way down to the
bottom and i felt it bend
i got to go through all the steps all
over again
still got that bend i'm gonna temper
overnight and
in that process it'll start to hopefully
normalize down it's hit or miss it's
either gonna go well
or it's gonna go wrong and and yeah it
went wrong today
it's morning of day two definitely had
some setbacks yesterday
starting the day with my ability tacked
up and ready for forge welding
and hoping to end the day with a
quenched and hardened spatha
first breath
looks okay so far but i'm still gonna be
really careful
i've got my billet drawn out pretty
close to shape
i have just enough length here uh you
can see i'm kind of forging in
that medial ridge already this is the
longest
blade i have ever attempted to quench
i pull the blade out of the oil at the
end of the day i have an intact damascus
blade so first thing tomorrow i'm going
to get my blade etched
and the handle prepared and looking
forward to a good day
i'm feeling better than last night
because i got the blade tempered and
got it straight still behind the ball
i'm gonna
start to fit up the handle start looking
at different parts and what i think
looks well so my design plan for this
pommel is i'm gonna take the two ends of
the deer antler and
i'm going to carve a lion's head out of
them hand carving anything
is time consuming so i can't get lost in
my head
i'll set it in on top of
glow-in-the-dark resin and then i'll
fill that in with a clear roxy
i'm not walking in there with something
plain tomorrow i'm gonna put some bronze
metal stain on the blade
and i'm gonna finish this no matter what
it'll be done
start at day four the fatigue of the
past couple days is definitely starting
to set in
the blade has been etched in the coffee
overnight to really bring out the
contrast
yeah it really darkened up that 1084.
so this spot that needs to have a wooden
guard and a disc shaped pommel so i'm
going to do a stacked handle
i'm using ironwood for the guard and the
pommel because it's super strong
and then i'm going to use black wood for
the main part of the handle
i've got all my individual pieces of
this handle fitted up nice and tight
got to get this blade sharpened and i've
never sharpened anything this long
before but
i know how to put an edge on a knife i
cannot wait to see this thing put to the
test
[Music]
word all right blade smiths your spot
spata swords look amazing
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage they can do
to do that i will take your weapon
deliver some killing slashes and blows
on this
more than willing ballistics dummy alex
you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
all right alex first up i can really
appreciate the beauty that you have with
your damascus pattern right there
it really stands out very clean
lines the medial ridge you have on here
i can imagine
how much work that takes to get it
almost perfectly
straight all the way through to the tip
your tip
is sharp enough to penetrate with the
thrust and lacerate on the way out and
most
importantly it will kill thank you good
job
all right gavin's your turn so you ready
hell yeah let's do this
alex's uh spot that just destroyed that
uh blow stick's dummy
and now i'm feeling anxious excited so i
got the adrenaline going
no medial ridge on either side of the
blade it's one of the parameters right
kevin your blade must fall within our
parameters in order to be tested evenly
and fairly with your competitors your
blade does not have a central ridge
that was a parameter that was outlined
before we ever sent you home
and for that reason you cannot be the
forged and fired champion
come on my friend you know it's just a
bummer i can't see a test
that's what i really want to see i want
to see how it holds up nice work on that
handle
thank you i appreciate it when i was
making it it had
the defined ridge in it just with the
sanding and grinding
it just took more of it off but uh this
whole experience has been a blast
congratulations this isn't a loss i'm
coming home with a ten
000 experience
alex you made a sharp and deadly spatha
but not only that you made something
that is detailed
and beautiful your attention to detail
has elevated you to the title of forged
and fire
champion congratulations your title
comes with a check
for 10 000 good job brother this is
pretty wild
i came here to challenge myself and put
myself through a
super rigorous test and i came out on
top and it feels great
it's ten thousand dollars i'm actually
gonna give it all straight to my parents
they supported me through college as i
was learning blade smithing and they're
both getting ready to retire so
that's all going to them
you